this is sworn to the sword oh I'm not
crying are you cry
no good there's no crying it's David
universe are you talking about this
plenty drunk do i sauces what's a lunch
a cartoon really would crying watch um
do opening - ah very good that scared
the hell out of me what the fuck is this
I just nothing I wasn't expecting okay
it was a good new opening it just it it
easily shocked this is it happened we
grew up boy shows we know openings have
to change know what to grow up to know
you should always be in front of a white
wall well I wasn't going to go there oh
no it's blue it on you think I've it off
yellow now it's a table actually
somebody did really cool I feel sound
tumbler what but they did like an
evolution of the wall and like the
different colors and stop it just see a
circle gradually from like a really hard
yellow to like you know can't lighter
than kind of what Lima gammab loosely
off-white now it's actual what it was
actually really cool um where we are
that was really cool um but uh yeah this
was a um this is intense
no you know and yet also very sing-songy
I always gotta say majority of it until
the end I thought like I thought just a
very charming episode just the way they
talked the way they interacted the way
they sang the song itself I'm like this
is a very you know it's funny when the
song started I actually really wasn't
into it it was like like I see I'm even
we got it - so here's a song in a while
we haven't heard a song about most of
songs so far I've been okay with but
this would start off in like a weird
purl say and like by the end of it I was
like oh you know I don't because it's a
mod time so the montage songs are we the
best that you know yeah sports Montana
and everything so now it really really
worried about
end of it I was like this is amazing
it's just saddling two and two for
something that you know mmm this is kind
of in the minor key in the piano and the
like it took me a minute to pick up up
what she was doing with the do it for
now do it for him or whatever like well
NZ uh even the opening song was very
nice um well what was that line where
she's like she fights off the seagulls
and she's like go back to your master
tell them we are not afraid I do that to
geese this way I like chase them away
and run back she got masters telling me
I'm not afraid
wing it Wow um but uh Canadian oh I hate
him too yeah you live in Chicago you
really fucking learn to hate it was
legal to hunt them around here I'd be
running on it's like we're very light
animal friendly stuff but that's the
ones like no they can go fuck themselves
okay whenever I look into the cold
soulless eyes of a Canadian goose I am
reminded of the fan yeah whenever those
things hiss new I'm like something
remind I'm very Mike yeah these things
really were descended from dinosaurs
yeah like this really odd little itty
like thought some little blossom Raptors
yeah any we're here but I stopped what a
shock we never do that um but uh yeah so
she is so pearl is training Connie now I
know what all these friggin because
every single time I see any clips or
someone tries to send me something
there's always a million shots of Connie
with a sword and I'm just like what is
this gonna happen go you've seen a
little bit but it's like really played
up in all these clips I keep seeing now
they're not even in the openings this is
carrying this kingdom I don't pull more
together - yeah no I really are it's
it's really super cheapest this whole
goddamn episode was super cute um I was
yeah to be their friends and then except
when pearl was just like you are nothing
and I'm like well yeah but I like that
um well there is something like
Scientology you know or nothing you will
work only for us you don't see it much
but I think there is kind of a mindset
that people can't put themselves in
where it's like they're so dedicated to
a cause or or a goal or something where
they will
just really and sometimes you got to put
yourself cat a second when you're trying
to achieve a goal whatever but sometimes
people will really really go to a point
where it's like no I am nothing there is
only this and they'll forget the value
of themselves uh you know and if
anything that can harm the goal you know
you need to know the value of I think
that was the I think that was at the end
when she's like well did Rose make you
feel like nothing and then it's like oh
shit yeah oh shit
snail bitch no I like that you know the
one thing I don't know it's like I like
this is good episode and I don't know
about this I wanna get your feedback
when she said you know why won't you let
me do this for you
Rose I felt I didn't need for her to say
roads I thought it was pretty obvious um
and something about when she sits down
again even though that was a nice moment
where they come and I really do like
that line - Rose make you feel like
nothing I I do kind of feel like you
know is every Perl episode gonna end
with her sitting down a kid or kids
coming up and comforting her and her
crying being like you know okay you know
kind of thing I maybe I just seen it was
early time no i-i've actually really
grown to love pearl that's why I think
when I see this again I'm kind of like I
want to see new aspects it's kind of
like you can't talk about pearl without
talking about Rose every single time and
I feel like there could be more to her
this than that she's still good
character I like her live scenes where
it wasn't just about Berlin Rose but
this is a major episode where she's
teaching Connie how to fight it makes
sense that they would go there I guess I
don't know it'd be that's a thing like
whatever there's a major episode about
pearl it's like oh it's oh it's gonna be
knows canary - art with Steven is ro so
it does make us that's what defines
pearl and Steven
is rose so yeah like it makes total
sense to me hmm
I do like the I like because like always
gonna be whining about using the force
like it's just it's what defines the
character like you got a you know no but
even Luke you know went into well hell
of it was the fire
yeah that's good sure yeah if it's what
defines the character then I know but
even look at the connection with his
father and stuff like belly he had a few
other things um you know the worse is
strong in my family no but even okay
even if he took the force out the
relationship between him his father
would have been interesting Oh being I
could probably find dozens of characters
where it's always about one or two
things it I think it's fine because
that's the defining moment in pearls
life is that so and it seems me like
she's working through her shit now like
that was part of it like realizing oh I
gotta work through this and you know I
think I I didn't I don't have a problem
with it at all
it's kind of like a gown oh there's a
good example bad example but like with
um I'll sever a few Zuko in Avatar and
the whole thing was other I need to get
back my honor mine are in people make
jokes about in the quad everywhere uh
and then in the second season you know
spoiler he's set on kind of a different
path but it's still kind of about his
honor but and then the third season kind
of they changes there too so I guess I'm
not seeing how many prove much
definitely how many Perl episodes that
toads have there been no better they're
not exactly it no that's an hour legit
point I guess I'm getting to instead
this eats wha but how about this without
you Randall something Eddie valiant just
please move beyond talking about his
damn dead brother it's no one if it was
a show if it was a show I would say that
uh but isn't just about it but if it was
a show put together like Steven universe
we'd still work what are we halfway
through what's been released so far
sound like that's a lot of to say and
yeah so no I I don't know I'm not saying
it's like chill bitch no I'm not saying
it's way table bitching I think it's
because I do like for uh Pro a lot so
you almost got the name wrong it's how
much are connected but uh I do like
pearl so much that I do and I'm
surprised at first ended up like okay I
know you need her but where she's kind
of my least favorite and I she's become
more and more interesting the acting's
become even better and better that it's
like I almost I want to see more beyond
Rose even though it's such a big part of
the her identity in the personality and
I get
that I feel like I need great-aunts very
nicely done
can I see just a little past that a
little something else but get on think I
got a rose is I think her whole story
arc here that baby I feel like I yeah I
want see something I don't know about
her yet if that makes sense like
becoming scarce I feel like I'm always
fighting fucking episode still to go
it's like you might be another time know
you might be right and it was cool
seeing her fight alongside rose I liked
her getting I really like that image of
her constantly getting killed over and
over the house fighting then we see
Connie go in and you know like oh yeah
that can't work out well shit um so and
no I really like this one I really like
that song um ya know if it really worked
in I'm not sure I would normally be all
over like just random musical numbers
and a harness Ramon is like yeah like I
mean Ave Animaniacs it's something that
was always the way the show is set up
but in a cartoon like this I'm just like
yeah I don't know if I can or maybe all
over there but they somehow really make
it work anytime you see to me it's like
I really like musicals if they're done
well I it's I'm kind of glad we're
seeing more of them because I think you
can do so much with them uh and when you
get to a montage you get that great
editing too and they you can do
counterpoint you get our character
singing different verses and so working
off of each other so anytime there's
like a musical number with a montage I
get really excited because I think
there's so many with with her it's a
Pearl Jam he made that joke while
watching this and Eileen just like was
the call oh oh no the best the best was
afterwards he just turns me and says how
could you would you that was better it
was great I've I've never seen such a
visceral reaction so betrayed you super
sorry I'm fed up with this pearl oh so
no a really a really good episode very
very salad good colors again you know
what I was just saying because it's
funny because I said pink is one of my
least favorite colors last at but they
really may work here and
yet the funny thing is there is so much
pink in this but it's a weird 70s muted
earth tone kind of pink that I really
enjoy it and they they use it really
well in this show if you try even like I
was saying the last one like some my
least favorite colors are like yellow
orange and brown line up but I think
like Prince of Egypt how well they used
of their well mine is like anything
you've done well can make you my least
favorite colors are actually pastels of
which pink is a part of it but these I
hate Easter colors when you're after
comes around and you get those pastel
yellows and and light blues and pink
their baby colors like that's I always
say I don't like baby colors and I'm a
dog but this the way they use shades of
pink in this show but they bring their
vibe really freaking words yeah well
whatever palette they're using I mean
they're very striking colors they're
they don't seem even when they're faded
they don't seem like they're not making
an impact they're still kept popping or
so Ken what's having girls shows we grew
up with like Jeff my little pony yeah
yeah Jim my gem barely got away with it
because it was very 80s hot pink but I
think like my little pony
Strawberry Shortcake rainbow brand like
yeah I I hate those color schemes even
some of them modern shows um like like
my the the new My Little Pony like I
nothing against the show personally it's
just like but the color schemes on it
I'm just kind of like oh man this isn't
any better than the original the
original no but yeah it's better than
the original but so yeah but that's just
my personal taste it's like there's just
some colors that bug me and uh this
really knows how to use it well so ya
know maybe they have a really good color
scheme in these episodes um so yeah
that's about it and we'll see you the
next one later not crying don't what's
it Pearl Jam